et Marie-Jacques
sont en patrouille au parc
de la Frayère à Boucherville.me)
Ils veillent à la conserva
des milieux naturels
dans la région.
cet environnementaliste milite
pour la protection
de l'habitat de la rainette
faux-grillon...
(coassements)
Une espèce menacée.
TOMMY MONTPETIT, directeur de la
-grillon
présentement dans le Grand
Montréal se porte très mal.
Lorsqu'on a commencé en 2003,
on avait déjà perdu 90 %
des effectifs de la rainette
faux-grillon. Puis
ce temps-là, on a perdu
un autre 30 à 40 %.t de la raine
et d'autres milieux naturels que
la Communauté métropolitaine
de Montréal adopte un règlement
qui interdira tous travaux
au nom de la lutte contre
les changements climatiques.VAÉ,
mairesse de Montréal
- C'est  que
ça se passe. J'ai envie
de vous dire qu'on n'a pas
le temps de niaiser.toire du Grl
est protégé, en y ajoutant
ces milieux terresdes
et l'habitat de la rainette
faux-grillon. Cette proportion
passerait à plus de 22 %,
soit l'équivalent de la
superficie l'île de Montréal.
- C'est énorme, c'est
un gestemportant.
JÉRÔ
- Je pense que c'est
une initiative qui est
très cotrès cotrès cotrès cotrè,
qui est nécessaire.
- Mais certains milieux naturels
ont déjà été détruits commremblr
le Canadien National.
CATHERIN
- Malheureusement, ce n'est pas
possible de rétablir le milieupr
de la rainette faux-grillon,
donc c'est très déplorable.
- Qu'est-ce qu'on entend aujust?
- Des grenouilles léopards.
- Des endroits comme celui-ci
On parle de plusieurs milliers
d'hectares qui vont être
protégés par ce règlement-là.
Donc, c'est vraiment quelque
depuis très longtemps.
- Un peu de répit pour
les espèces qui y vivent.ar
la Communauté métropolitaine
de Montréal entrera en vigueurdr
le gouvernement du Québec.
La ministre des Affaires
décider de l'approuver ou non.
Ici Sébastien Desrosiers,
Radio-Canada, Longueuil.